the opening scene features two young
boys named shin and heel who are
orphaned due to the war and are sold as
slaves to a small village on their way
to the Village they witness a heroic
entry of one of the great generals named
Uki who is leading thousands of troops
behind him the boys are clearly
captivated by the immense power he
possesses upon reaching the village an
elderly man assigns the boys to labor
tasks and provides them with only a
modest stable for rest despite the harsh
circumstances they don't make any
complaints and support each other in
their work as time goes by their bond
deepens evolving into a profound
friendship they even share the same
passion and dream of escaping their low
status and becoming great generals
despite knowing that getting rid of the
slavery class isn't easy at all in order
to pursue their dream the boys spend
their free time in the forest to
practice their combat skills they also
make swords using wood in order to learn
the sword handling techniques several
years pass and the two boys grow up but
they still continue their practice in
the forest it has turned them into
remarkable Fighters one day during their
training session General Chiang Wan Joon
spots them he seems to be impressed by
Hugh's swordsmanship and thinks of a
plan later that day Upon returning home
after Gathering wood from the forest the
boys discover that General Chang is
waiting for them it turns out that his
purpose of visiting the villages to
search for a great soldier who can serve
the king kin Jang surprisingly he has
already picked the soldier and it is
none other than Hugh the latter is taken
aback by this sudden development and he
wonders if it is the right time to
depart however Shin who is really happy
for his best friend encourages him to
achieve his dream he also promises that
he will work harder and soon catch up to
heal on that night before parting ways
the two best friends have one last
practice duel pledging to reunite in the
near future starting the following day
Shin begins to train more diligently in
the forest as well as in the hillside
with an unwavering determination to
enhance his fighting skill after several
months of Hardcore training his strength
heightens to the point where he is able
to shatter a Boulder using his wooden
sword it's all in the rest one night
Shin is resting in his stable after his
training when he hears a knock on his
door when he opens it he shockingly
finds a Gravely wounded Hue in his dying
State he talks about the turmoil within
the kingdom he reveals that the reigning
King's younger brother saikyo has
actually hired some assassins to finish
off the royal family before breathing
his last Hugh hands Shin a map and urges
him to go to the marked Village from
which he can find a way to fulfill his
dream after learning all of this Shin
grabs Hugh's sword and escapes The
Village just before the Assassins arrive
reluctantly leaving his best friend's
body behind on the way he comes across a
group of local Thugs who surround him
and demand the valuable sword in his
hand Shin tells them to clear the way as
he doesn't want to get into an
unnecessary fight but when the thugs
don't comply he with the help of his
long intensive training easily takes
down every one of them after running for
several miles Shin finally arrives at
his destination a small Hut once inside
he is shocked to discover an individual
bearing and uncanny resemblance to heal
this leaves Shin perplexed as he is
unable to comprehend what is happening
the individual turns out to be none
other than the king Zhang who had run
away from the kingdom Zhang reveals that
General Chang had intentionally brought
Hugh into the palace due to his striking
similarity to the king this ruse was
intended to deceive the undercover
officials who wanted to kill the king
unfortunately he was sacrificed for the
cause meanwhile back in the village the
Assassins led by General Saji find the
lifeless body of Hugh it only takes
moments for the astute General to deduce
the truth the deceased individual is a
decoy while the true king is still alive
as a result he issues orders to locate
the King dead or alive as soon as
possible on the other hand Shin is very
furious at King Jiang after learning
that his best friend died in his place
and didn't even hide the body which made
the whole plan useless but before he can
exact his rage on him they are suddenly
attacked by an assassin sent by Prince
psycho knowing that the Assassins are
the ones who killed Hugh Shin becomes
even angrier and starts fighting with
the Enemy eventually using his Superior
skills he manages to kill the Assassin
after this he gets back to King Zhang
and demands why he had to kill his best
friend in response Zhang reveals that he
bravely agreed to sacrifice his life in
order to save the kingdom despite
knowing about the potential danger
furthermore Zhang also claims that he
had to stay alive to prevent his younger
brother from capturing the kingdom if
all the powers fell into psycho's hand
he would take no time to destroy the
entire Kingdom King Zhang then asks Shin
to unite forces and assist him in
reclaiming the throne saying it is the
best way to honor Hugh's sacrifice in
the next scene we see Prince psychiao
who is very angry to hear the news that
his brother is still alive his anger
also extends to General Chang who hired
a decoy to save Zhang's Life as a result
Prince psycho orders the capture of both
Chang and Zhang demanding their heads as
trophies amid their discussions the
formidable General Uki shows up in the
palace and presents the severed head
claiming that it belongs to Chang
impressed by this the prince appoints
him as the Kingdom's new General
charging him with the mission of
apprehending Zhang elsewhere Zhang and
shin are walking through the forest when
they are soon accompanied by a mountain
tribe kid named Helia odiao together the
trio makes their way through the
mountain path as they reach the bamboo
forest they are attacked by another
assassin who uses poisoned darts and an
ax as his weapons Shin grabs his sword
and bravely engages in a fierce battle
against the adversary after an immense
fight he manages to slash the enemy's
head with his sword but one of the
poisoned darts seems to have hit his
body rendering him unconscious following
this Zhang and heliao take him to an
abandoned resort to help him recuperate
a while later Shin regains his
Consciousness and has a brief
conversation with Zhang before long a
group of soldiers arrive at the resort
led by none other than General Chang who
has previously assumed to have been
killed here it is revealed that the
Haruki presented to Prince psycho was
just a trick Zhang who is still loyal
towards the king collaborates with him
to devise a strategy for reclaiming the
throne from Prince psycho's grasp
however Zhang is hesitant to go into
battle as his men are severely
outnumbered by psycho's Army of 80 000
troops hearing this Chang suggests
seeking help from the mountain tribe a
former Ally of the Zhang royal family
that had been betrayed centuries ago
Chang points out that they can form a
larger Army Alliance if the tribe agrees
this convinces Zhang so all of them head
towards the mountain tribal area after a
long and treacherous walk they all
arrive at the Borderlands of the
mountain tribe's territory but before
they can enter the place they are
captured by the soldiers of mountain
tribe and bro brought forth to their
Chieftain named yutanwa Zhang extends
apologies on behalf of their ancestors
and implores the tribe's assistance in
reclaiming his kingdom the chieftain
initially rejects The Plea citing the
significant losses endured by the tribe
due to the actions of Zhang's Kingdom in
the past however the king remains
undeterred and he explains the
consequences if his brother claims the
throne hearing all of this yutanwa is
impressed by Zhang's dedication towards
his kingdom so she announces that the
mountain tribe will be affiliated with
the Zhang royalty once again having
secured this Alliance King Jiang shares
his plan to attack the Royal forces from
various directions the next day Zhang
and his troops disguised themselves as
members of the mountain tribe and
advanced towards the Royal Palace when
they reach it yutanwa engages Prince
psycho's advisor proposing an alliance
with the prince the advisor relays this
information to Prince psycho and after a
brief discussion they agree to establish
the alliance however only 50 of the
mountain tribes are allowed for now in
order to carry out the further
discussion in the next scene the group
of 50 the kingdom and soon launches
their attack on the enemies adhering to
the devised plan Zhang divides his
forces into two factions one group led
by shin and Chang while the second group
led by yutanwa and himself Shin's group
uses the underground passageway to reach
the throne room while Zhang's group uses
the main route although the evil Prince
has thousands of men at his disposal
they are of no match against the skilled
king and the mountain tribes on the
other hand Shin's group is intercepted
by General Saji who dispatches a giant
executioner against them although the
group initially struggles to overpower
the giant Shin eventually manages to
kill him with the United group effort
after this they break into the Royal
Palace with the intent to assassinate
Prince psycho however the prince remains
seemingly unaffected as he has several
guards under his command psycho summons
one of his most potent generals Saji to
eliminate The Intruders the latter gets
to work and easily overpowers a portion
of the mountain tribe's soldiers amidst
this confrontation Shin is challenged to
a one-on-one duel against Saji which he
accepts without hesitation a fierce
sword fight that ensues between the two
with both of them showcasing their
exceptional fighting skills over time
Saji gains the upper hand delivering
some powerful blows that inflict a lot
of damage upon Shin nevertheless our
hero's memory of Hugh and belief in his
own dreams pushes him to continue with
his never giving up attitude he finally
manages to stop Saji to death after
witnessing the losing battle psycho's
Council attempts to flee but Helia stops
him and gouges out his eye with a dart
in retaliation the advisor stabs Helio
before he succumbs to the dart's poison
fortunately Helio is safe thanks to her
strong armor taking advantage of this
distraction psycho attempts to flee but
when he reaches outside he is confronted
by his brother and the entire Mountain
tribe Army Zhang with a single Mighty
blow of the sword swiftly overpowers
psycho and then subjects him to a series
of punches as punishment but despite
everything that has happened he
ultimately chooses to spare his
brother's life a short while later
General Uki along with his forces shows
up in the courtyard and questions Jiang
about the reason why he fought this
intense battle in reply Zhang explains
that he could not permit the abuse of
Royal Authority by any traitor so he
further inquires what he will do as king
and warns that he will behead him if he
does not provide a satisfactory answer
Zhang shares his determination to unite
China under the Warring States era even
if it requires using Force to secure
peace in the future the answer please
izuki and he forms an alliance with
Zhang he then orders the remaining
forces under psycho's command to retreat
however one of the steadfast generals
who is loyal to Psycho refuses to comply
he charges forward to attack Zhang
instead seeing this General Uki Simply
Smiles before incapacitating the entire
force in a single masterful move in the
final scene Jenga sends back to his
throne while Shin Revels in the glory of
making both his and Hugh's dreams come
true subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
for watching